There are times on this channel when
I know exactly what I'm gonna be doing.
This is not one of those times!
The production crew just said
that I should meet here...
...on a farm in Ayrshire?
Spot on, yes.
And meet Cammy Wilson from
The Sheep Game.
And I don't know what's happening now!
What's gonna happen?
Well Tom, I've got a very exciting day
planned for you today.
We're gonna try our hand
at some sheep herding.
Right, okay.
Got a nice little
tame group for you today.
(laughs) Okay, thank you.
I say tame.
I don't know how this is gonna go.
(both laugh)
I never know how this is gonna go!
So we're gonna try
working with a sheep dog.
We're gonna try and see
how your whistling is.
We have a specific sheep dog whistle...
Right, okay.
...for you to try.
But it's gonna be interesting.
We'll see how that goes.
We do have a backup plan...
Okay.
...for if things don't work
with the dog.
I have a feeling they might not.
But we'll...
So no matter what today,
we'll get these sheep in.
Alright.
But it just might not be with the dog.
Alright. (both laugh)
She's not gonna pay attention to
some city boy who's...
...who's been...
parachuted in here!
There's a good chance that is correct.
(laughs)
But we're about to find out.
Alright!
Away. Shh-shh!
Lie down, lie down.
Away. Shh!
(softly) Lie down, lie down.
You're speaking very quietly,
and she's still getting it.
(to Meg) Come by, come by.
(to Tom) It's a lot to do with tone as well.
So sometime— Lie down!
If she's being a bit pushy,
you'll be a bit firmer.
Lie down, lie down.
How's your lie-downs?
(both laughing)
How bad is it gonna be if
I try and imitate a Scottish accent?
That's not gonna be—
No, that'd... surely add to the humour.
Come by.
Okay, I hear three commands.
Mhm.
"Lie down" is obvious.
Yep.
"Come by" and "away"?
So "come by" is to go to the left,
and "away" is to go to the right.
Now, a lot of people will—
The dog's right or your right?
The dog's right.
Okay.
Come by.
I—I'm amazed how she just...
...she can hear you
from such a long distance.
Yeah, I suppose that goes back to
dogs and their incredible hearing.
But she's almost...
waiting for the commands.
So you know she's listening for it.
At the time, and yeah,
she's so responsive.
Even... you know...
Nine is getting quite old for a sheep dog.
She's losing a bit of speed.
But her hearing certainly seems
to still be working...
(both laughing)
...to full effect, which is great.
But she pushes her luck some days.
I saw that!
Although she's nine years old,
she's still like a teenager.
She's like, "No, I don't wanna lie down,
I wanna keep chasing them!"
Okay so, if
— which I believe is highly likely —
that Meg probably won't listen
to anything you say...
Yeah, okay. Alright.
We have a backup plan.
I got you one of these.
Now this...
...is a sheep dog whistle.
You got that engraved!
That's got my name on it!
(laughs happily)
Now, that is a... that's a keepsake for you
Oh, thank you!
to remember this whole experience.
Oh, that's lovely.
But a very popular thing with—
Most shepherds will have one
around their neck, most of the time.
Yeah.
The hard thing is,
it's a beautiful thing to look at.
This is not like a sport whistle,
where you just blow and...?
No, it's not like the dog whistle
that many would know,
that's high-pitch frequency.
There's a fair knack to it, so...
It's gonna be fun watching you try—
Hey, you might surprise me.
The idea is that your tongue
goes on the edge here.
Okay. Yep.
Of the whistle, and you just blow.
(in whistle code) That'll do. Away. Come by.
(blows)
I'm gonna be honest... (coughs)
(blows wetly)
(wheezes)
I'm gonna be honest,
I think we might wanna try the voice first(?)
(giggles) Yeah.
The voi-pff.
(rasps) (whistles briefly)
I think we'll make this—
Oh—!
(whistles weakly)
(whistling intensifies)
Ohh, he's a sheep farmer now!
(whistles)
There is a very confused dog
over there!
(both laugh)
I think, although we're
getting some good tones here...
We'll try the voice first?
We'll go with the voice.
I would send her
to the right first, here.
That's what I was thinking of doing,
so that's good(!)
That would be—
That would be...
say it quite loudly, "Away."
"Away" is right, "come by" is left, right?
Yep, yep.
So in theory...
Away.
(wheezes)
(mouthing) Nah.
One word from me,
and she does absolutely nothing.
Not even a flinch.
Not even— Didn't even flinch.
Away! ...Yourself?
Away.
Lie down, lie down.
That'll do Meg, lie down.
I mean, what I'm gonna try and do...
Do the accent?
I know! I feel like I need permission
to do the accent.
Just do it.
Be as Scottish as you can be.
Away!
Ooh.
Oh...?
There we go, that was—
Away!
No, she's just confused.
Deepen it.
(deeper voice) Away! Away.
Away.
And slower. "Ah-wee."
Try to give it a wee bit.
Away!
No. She knows it's not you!
(laughs)
Go for it, go for it.
Away!
But she knows, you're getting your own—
She knows the minute—
Do you know, that was
such a flashback too.
That's exactly what she was like
with me when I first started.
Lie down.
(softly) Nothing.
Lie down!
She got a wee flinch.
She knows the command, but she's...
Lie down!
The /l/, she's got the /l/.
Try it again.
Lie down!
Try it with the "Away."
Away!
(softly) No! She hears the—
(softly) Go for a
right deep, long "Ah-weee".
Away! No.
The voice is just wrong.
(laughs) Yes!
It's like the wee wire in her head says,
"That's a command, but oh, that wasn't him."
No. That's not the... (chuckles)
Not the right person there.
Away.
She's so smart!
Makes me feel so powerful now.
She's so smart though!
(laughs)
'Cause you can see the flinch,
and you can see
that she knows where to go,
the intonation—
Every little detail of the
command in your voice...
Yep.
...she's got, and she's following.
And... immediately,
over the hill, pulling the sheep back.
Yeah, it's a...
Incredible.
Real interesting to see her actually,
'cause I've not done that for six years.
So it's great to see how she reacted
there like this, and it's good to see—
Exactly as you say, she knows...
what she's meant to do,
but it's just not
any person saying it.
You try and tell her to lie down now.
Lie down.
Lie down!
Nice and firm.
(gruffly) Lie down!
Ohh!
Ohh! (laughs and claps)
That was good, try "come by".
Come by!
(gasps) We're away now.
We're away.
Lie down! Lie down!
Lie down! Nope.
(laughs)
Lie down, lie down.
(both giggle)
It's so...
I was gonna go up, but there's
something there— There's potential here.
She might come home with you yet.
(chuckles)
Try "away" again.
Away!
Oh...
There we go. It's...
She's getting the hang of it.
She's getting it.
Try a "lie down" there.
Lie down! Lie down!
(wheezes)
Lie down! No...!
Your Scottish is quite good though!
(both laughing)
I just said you'd do that.
Lie down!
Go ahead.
Lie down. Lie down, Meg.
Hey, lie down.
Oh, I'm confusing her now.
No, it's actually 'cause she standing there.
Oh, so she's calmed down.
Well, 'cause she's already standing still.
She's like, "Well, what more can I do?
What difference will lying down make?"
So I'd send them left here?
Yeah, try it. Have a go.
So that's "come by"?
Come by! Come by.
(grunts)
Come by.
(softly) Better lie down there.
Lie down! Lie down!
Nice and firm.
Lie down!
...Right, yeah.
So the "come by" I can nail.
Yeah.
But I think it's an accent,
it's a tone-of-voice thing.
It's an experience thing.
I'm actually amazed that
she's done what she's done.
(chuckles)
Like...
Like, I just honestly thought
we would get nowhere with this.
Oh, I thought we'd get—
But the number of times
she's flinched and she's gone,
"That's not— I'm confused.
That's not right."
Yeah, yeah. It's a...
What might help is my partner.
She's English.
(laughs)
And she walks with Meg sometimes.
And so, I think she—
Maybe she thinks you're her! (giggles)
So I think that definitely—
'Cause honestly, I thought we'd get nowhere.
I'm really chuffed.
Yeah.
So she's a good distance away.
What about trying another "away".
Away!
Hey!
She's basically your dog now(!)
So, set up a pen, see if we can...?
Yeah, I think we could.
I honestly didn't see it
going that way.
I think we could really try something.
I think it's Meg doing
most of the work here, rather than me.
But even just the fact
she's responding is fantastic.
So yeah, let's get a pen set up,
and see if we can get them in it.
Alright! (both laughing)
I mean, I hate to use the phrase,
"How hard can it be?"
But... can you train sheep?
(laughs)
Like, if they see the pen, do they aim for it?
Oh no. If they see the pen,
they realise what you're doing,
and they decide to run away from it.
Right, okay, good.
That's the problem, so we try
and make it in a corner like this,
where we can use the fence line
as a bit of an extra guide.
Right.
I'll just pull this around,
and I think we're... good to go.
So, I've got a goal.
We have a goal, yes.
And when— So the sheep...
through there and...?
We'll just keep them
in here for just now.
If we were gonna be doing anything
with them, like drenching them,
or clipping tails, or doing anything at all,
giving them minerals,
they would come in here,
and it's a nice space to work with.
And they're gonna go through there, one at a time.
And then they run out the front.
Right.
There's a kinda... the end goal here.
Get 'em in, we'll have a nice look
and enjoy the success.
Then we'll let 'em back out.
(both laughing)
Ah, love the optimism!
Yes. Brilliant.
Where are these sheep now?
I can't actually see.
I see—
Hang on, there's Meg.
So my instinct says...
going out to the left.
Yes, I would—
And keep them to the fence line.
If I go to the right,
they're gonna scatter all over the field.
I would agree.
And left is... "come by"?
Yep.
So, alright. Let's see if it works.
Come by!
Come by.
Oh yes... (quiet laugh)
Away! Away!
(quiet laugh)
So, I would try your "see",
and get her to look back.
See, see!
Even if I try a Scottish accent,
she's not doing anything.
You need to tell her that one.
See, see!
See!
So she's scanning, looking, she knows—
Come by!
There we go, okay.
When she locks her eyes,
I give the command.
Yep. Alright, so she's gonna
bring those back here.
The catch is—
Get her to lie down there.
Lie down, lie down,
lie down!
Lie down!
Send her right.
...Away!
I made that difficult for you.
I know you did— Oh hang on.
See if you say "That'll do",
see if she'll come to you.
That'll do, that'll do.
That'll do.
A little hard, this one. She's just
got herself in an awkward spot here.
Do you wanna bring...?
That'll do, Meg. That'll do, Meg.
Give those sheep space.
Lie down there. Right.
Now imagine you're—
I mean, at this point, I can just...
You do that.
That's One Man and His Dog style.
Now get ready with that left command.
Away, away!
No, "come by".
Come by!
That's it. Oh.
No.
(groans)
Oh! That's...
Lie down, lie down.
See if you can guide that one back.
And come back to its pals.
He's more likely
to break that way, I think.
I'm being outwitted by a sheep!
You watch the main flock,
and she should come back.
No, we've lost 'em! (groans)
(laughs)
So close!
(both laughing)
I mean, thank you
for the advice and assistance.
Oh hang on, hang on,
hang on, hang on.
I mean, she's smarter than me
at this, isn't she?
So she wants—
We want her to come...
Keep her pressure off there.
Tell her to lie down.
There we go. Lie down, lie down,
lie down, lie down.
Lie down!
Ohh—!
That's it. Grab your gate and
drag it 'round behind them.
That's it, drag it 'round!
(laughs, applauds)
I did not expect that to work!
Fantastic.
Meg! (laughs)
Fantastic. Hey.
Meg, you've just made shepherding
look so easy!
(both laughing)
No, to be fair...
The number of times
you just said, "See"...
...and she looked around and went,
"split flock, there they are, I need to do this"...
and she's just... so, so clever!
She's, yeah...
Listen, I couldn't do my job without her.
Without a doubt, she's fantastic.
And I'm just— Honestly.
I'm so chuffed that she listened to you.
I'm amazed, 'cause that first time...
she just looked and went...
"Who's this prick?"
(both laughing)
Exactly!
I didn't wanna say that, of course.
Yeah, she had that look in her eye,
but she looks at me
most days like that!
(both laughing)
So no, you did well, Meg.
You did well.
Hey thank you, Meg.
You're a good pup. You're a good pup.
You're going home with Tom, ey?
(both laughing)
Okay, that went...
far better than I expected.
Yeah. Yeah.
But I had a backup plan.
And we're gonna do the
backup plan anyway, 'cause...
I thought, we went to all this bother.
We've got this bike here.
It's been a long while since
I've ridden one of these.
It's always a good bit of fun though, eh?
Yeah...
So, we've got it here anyway.
We may as well have a go.
I'm gonna try and
round up sheep... with this?
Yeah. Meg's gone.
She's away for a well-deserved rest.
Yep.
Just you and the bike now.
(cackles)
And this small pen.
Okay!
This is ridiculous. Okay.
Here we go!
(motor revving)
We're getting perserverance.
I like that determination.
It's an important trait
when we're working with sheep every day.
He's good, he doesn't
push them too hard, it's brilliant.
'Cause these things—
The sheep know we're trapping them,
so they're gonna keep
trying to break.
I'm actually watching, wondering if I can
even get them in with the bike, to be honest.
(laughs)
I'm so used to using Meg!
I wouldn't even know!
Perfect angle there, Tom.
That's good.
I'll just... be a little guide as well.
Come on, come on!
No you don't!
You're going that way!
I'll be a little help
here as well.
Ohh! (laughs)
They've just decided...
this isn't happening.
I feel like the jumps were mocking me!
(laughs)
I feel like...
I feel like the little jumps there
were mocking me!
I'll try and offer
a bit of assistance...
just as a...
a little guide here.
Teamwork makes the dream work.
(motor revving aggressively)
Oh, he's got it. Read it well.
Keep them up tight to the fence.
Can we get a bit of help from
one man here, along with the ATV?!
(chuckles)
I'll be your— I'll be your guide.
(motor stalls)
I've stalled it!
It's unbelievable.
(motor humming)
Oh, we're so close. We're so close.
Come on.
Close the gate!
(laughing)
Yes, well done!
(laughs)
Well done, that was amazing.
Thank you!
Tell you what, Meg is
much better at that than I am.
I was thinking,
what would Meg do at this point?
Having watched
what the dog knew to do...
it's like, "Alright, I just gotta..."
She's also a lot more
manoeuvrable than this thing(!)
Yeah, I did notice that a couple times,
but I thought you did very well.
Thank you.
You're the all round sheep farmer now.
I'm really not. Thank you so much!
I'll give you a job any day, Tom.
Thanks for coming down. Brilliant.
Come on. Hey-hey-hey.
Come on, pups.
Here you go. Hey.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]
What do you see?